we'll just read the news you can trust
him yeah I trust you trust me I'm
reading the news there we go all right
here we go my friends from Fox News
Netflix protesters Furious over
Chappelle's special attack man with we
like Dave sign no no they didn't attack
a man with a sign that said we like Dave
they attacked a man holding a sign that
said we like Dave I think the title is
kind of funny some activists have called
for Netflix to remove the controversial
Dave Chappelle special everyone spells
Dave Chappelle Wrong by the way that's
that's always look at this yeah I was
just wondering that actually it's two
P's right yeah how dare they so this
video is just absolutely hilarious by
the way and I guess we're not getting
any sound either so uh there you can see
there it's just a sign that says we like
Devil actually you can't see anything
you can't see anything I'll tell you
what's happening there's a guy holding
up a sign that says we like Dave the
crowds the mob surrounds him just Stomps
on it destroys it and then starts
screaming he's got a weapon what this is
amazing there's a tweet from the daily
wire if someone wants to go check it out
yeah yeah so I think I think Netflix
loves this you think so I think I think
they love I think that's why the was it
the vice president uh came out and
talked about taking his oh I'm so sorry
I apologize we never should have done
this but you notice he didn't take it
down right because this thing is doing
gangbusters in terms of views and more
controversy means more people are going
to view it so at the end of the day I
think Netflix is secretly very happy all
this is going on they might be
organizing the protests
are you kidding from a marketing
perspective if you've got a book coming
out if you've got something coming out
and protesters are going to come out
there after you given today's
environment yeah that's what you want
it's exactly what you want well they
were well the mainstream media was
talking about a thousand employees
walking out of Netflix I think it's safe
to say that it definitely wasn't a
thousand people it was some people that
went vapid and crazy because one guy had
a sign and stood there peacefully saying
we like Dave and they responded as if he
was he was kind of criminal I'm pretty
sure he was chanting trans lives matter
too I wasn't he wasn't opposed to me
just like I like Dave he's a funny guy
and they were so I'm screaming at him
well a couple guys jumped on him took
his sign down ripped it away tore it
apart and then made sure he couldn't
have it he had to stick they said the
stick was weapon they pushed him and
they came up and they said free speech
MFR and they got really cool the lady
was like screaming she was like evil be
gone so I saw Dave Chappelle in in
Nevada a couple of weeks before this
thing dropped it was right before the um
the McGregor fights we were out for that
and it was Will Chamberlain's bachelor
party and we were with Tom Sauer and a
bunch of people and so that was one of
those sort of like no you know no cell
phone shows but I think that a lot of
the similar kind of bits and stories
that he was telling at that show and
Rogan came and did like an opening act
and um tatsukura was there as well and I
remember one of the big things that
Chappelle was talking about that that
night and I've heard that it's he
repeats the story again on the special
is that he had a very close friend who
he was a fan she was trans and then was
bullied for being friends with Dave
Chappelle and then ends up killing
herself and he was sort of just telling
her story and saying how he's like you
can be friends with someone who's trans
you can treat them respectfully but this
movement right the politization of it
has gotten out of hand and oh by the way
my friend died as a result of this
Dave's losing this think he's losing
absolutely losing his his uh Sticks and
Stones was hilarious it was amazing it
was offensive he did that's the last
special not this one is a closer the
latest one it is the closest whatever
you're saying that's the special Sticks
and Stones the one before was amazing
what happened he got attacked but we all
joked saying they can't get Dave
Chappelle he's too famous he's too big
everybody likes the guy right right but
they did put a crack in the hole and if
you watch the closer man half of the bit
is basically him complaining about
getting attacked for it no that was the
whole show when I saw him too it was
actually it was a little bit he got to
his head I fell asleep I fell asleep
during the show I was like I got to his
head where's the where's the comedy
where's that and then he said I'm not
gonna do these jokes anymore because I
don't think they get it it's like he's
caving in wow now the Netflix CEO is
like oh I should have uh uh did it
better because our employees are hurting
and then you get all of these psychos
this cult and it's a cult man when they
start screaming evil be gone and they're
acting as if they're in some kind of
like
Hollow fundamental simulacrum of a
religion or something
they have lost their screaming burn the
witch is that what they're screaming no
I'm I'm saying but I'm paraphrasing
right that it's that's a I'm joining
parallel between that that it's they've
declared that Dave Chappelle is a witch
and that anybody who supports him well
then you're also going along so let's
take a look at like Amy Schumer's neck
look special everybody hated it it was
yeah I mean awful well just think of all
those clips that went viral of the great
jokes from Amy Schumer that we've all
yeah exactly and the controversy there
was some clips because she was saying
just really disgusting things and people
thought she was trying to go for like
shock content oh yeah yeah she was
talking about she talks a lot about
disgusting bodily functions right and uh
people were just like I don't understand
how I relate to this and so that's when
Netflix got rid of the star system and
said we're gonna do a thumbs up thumbs
down I guess is that is that what they
do thumbs up thumbs down now or
something
so something like that but it's it's so
annoying to me because I liked the Tsar
system when they had that right yeah you
know you should be able to see okay do
people like this thing that's good how
much which Amazon has on Prime you can
actually see that and there's other
services out there other streaming
services will at least give like the
IMDb score so you have some kind of an
idea but Netflix it's gone
now we have Dave Chappelle who is wildly
popular audience loved the show Even
though this one was very much him like
eulogizing you know his career like I
can't do this anymore I'm not going to
be doing a special he talked so much
about how they went after him and how
his friend died over it and he's he's
he's like basically saying like I can't
do this
so now they're they're protesting
outside of Netflix they're getting what
they want the CEO is starting to back
down he's like I should have thought
about this and the the cracks are
forming Dave Chappelle was a much harder
Target to get to get taken down but
they're succeeding yeah and the more you
allow this to continue the more you say
well I'm gonna go along with it even
though you know it's ridiculous and you
know he's clearly wasn't saying anything
that was negative any of the stuff that
doesn't even matter no I just have to
accuse him of you are giving them a win
you're giving them a win because you're
letting them set the frame of the debate
you're letting them set the narrative
and you're bending the knee at the end
you know you're bending the knee this
reminds me of uh South Park when the
hippies are coming to South Park and
yeah you want to do the music festival
right they arrest Cartman and then
they're like this Festival is going to
be great for us Eric why would you try
and stop it we're going to make tons of
money and there's like hey please don't
have money and then that's it happening
which is the corporations you're the
sick Groove yeah exactly it's like he
plays Slayer and gets blood Rain by
player and gets everyone to go away but
isn't that the one where they have the
um they have like the van that they
drive through the crowds yeah and
they're like don't go out there yeah
it's like the movie The Core but I I
bring that up because Dave Chappelle
popular funny and Netflix is slowly
being weakened by a a horde of deranged
people screaming psychotic things
why is anyone listening to these people
meanwhile it's good for the
establishment I guess to control culture
I haven't seen clips of any of that of
Dave Chappelle going viral but I'll tell
you what Clips are going viral it's Norm
Macdonald right the Norm McDonald Clips
the stuff that people are digging up
from throughout his career and the
reason he was popular was because he was
Politically Incorrect and he would say
things that if there was a sacred cow he
would step on it and mock it and make
fun of it and criticize it in a way that
you know whether it was Hillary Clinton
or O.J Simpson or whatever literally
whatever it was
um he was even making fun of um the way
Democrats were spinning January 6th if
you go to his Twitter feed there's a few
tweets up him uh I think from the day
actually from that very day and you know
that was his entire career because he
was just being real do you see that
that's what people want you see they're
going after Jon Stewart now good he
deserves it he deserves every bit of it
Jon Stewart but why why does Jon Stewart
deserve it because he's a horrible
person you think so he's disgusting
person he's responsible for the
gamification of politics he's one of the
people along with a very much him really
very much him yes if you look at what he
did with the Daily Show he decided that
and he went under and then he goes on a
crossfire right and it was Tucker right
and that was the show where they had one
it was always it started with Buckley
and they would always have sort of one
conservative one liberal and they would
sit down and they would debate but they
would at least have a conversation Jon
Stewart goes on a crossfire blows it up
and says you shouldn't be talking to
each other we shouldn't have
conversations with each other instead he
then he goes over to the Daily Show and
what does he do you know he's not really
a political guy he didn't come to
um to Media with any kind of political
background but what did he know he knew
talk radio and specifically sports radio
and so he turned the Daily Show and
which was a pop culture show right a pop
culture show originally under Craig
Kilbourne which was fantastic
um that he turned it into essentially
sports radio but his team was the
Democrats I mean
Jon Stewart praised project Veritas on
more than one occasion when oh I think
he's I think he's trying to atone right
but this is this is back in the day I
think he's trying to the Run of The
Daily Show I can't give it to him no
can't give it to him well relative to
where we're at now you know his
willingness to be like look at this guy
and look what he did and now you have
you know John Oliver Jordan klepper Jim
Jefferies garbage trash
is that Stewart started that yeah but
there's an organization of Comedy
there's a big difference between someone
who's like here are things that I think
we should talk about and then someone
being like hey look at this formula we
can extract from that right but think of
it too this way it he changes the
formula of Comedy as Oppo instead of
like I think you're putting it on him
when it's the when it's Comedy Central
when it's when it's HBO when it's these
to an extent but how many years was he
the host of The Daily Show
thousands or something nine seasons was
it was it nine was it was a long time it
was a long time yeah it was like really
long time and so he changed it from
instead of the punch line being so the
idea of you know like a Norm Macdonald
where the idea of a punch line is a um
you know you're not you're you're
getting this phrase but you're giving
you're you're not giving someone their
expectations right you're subverting
expectations your unexpected punch line
he took that away he took away the punch
line and so the punch line became look
at these stupid people they think things
that are different than us he hosted it
for 16 years 16 99 2015. well now he's
come out and he said I believe it was
2015. he said the media is focused too
heavily on Trump acting like he's the
greatest threat we need to you know get
back to reality and now they're all
saying because he did
the entire time the entire I'm sorry
like I just don't buy any of the Jon
Stewart like you know retribution tour I
don't I don't know
Bill Maher is like all of a sudden now
I'm playing to a mixed audience and
people are craving comedy mocking
wokeness and it's like yes bill because
people who are liberal back then are
still the same political same
politically but we watch videos of these
this group of unhinged Psychopaths
outside of Netflix and I'm supposed to
relate to that as the left yeah please
no Jack I would disagree with you a
little bit because I believe Bush
deserved a lot of criticism and he was
only getting it on Jon Stewart and some
other shows but but everyone especially
early on in his presidency loves him and
adored him but he was also one of the
few people that actually criticized
Obama and was actually able to break
that barrier now I understand your
bigger point when he kind of politicized
comedy and wielded it as a weapon I
think more effectively than anybody else
out there and he did it for his side and
I think you make a compelling argument
about that
um
he's patient zero this wasn't you know
and then when Jimmy Jimmy Kimmel is kind
of like you know a great example of
someone who became infected by this
right you can go and see Jimmy Kimmel
early on when he's doing um what was the
game show he had of Ben Stein and then
he's on the man show and then when Ben
Stein's Money when Ben Stein's Money
yeah
yeah obviously yeah Colbert was twist
and then you know and that yeah even
Colbert originally was just kind of like
a parody but then right they go through
this filter they pass through this
filter they realize the weaponization of
it they realize the political power of
comedy and now you turn it on and every
single I don't know he's the host of The
Tonight Show I disagree I don't I don't
think I don't think uh it starts with
Stuart I don't think so that's pretty I
don't think a bunch of Democrats were
like wow look how powerful this is I
think certainly there were some what I
think happened was after The Daily Show
was was winding down they were like how
do we do more of this people love it and
so they were like John Oliver let's
let's do a completely formulaic man I've
been watching House reruns lately I've
been watching you know how season one
and uh you guys know House MD right oh
yeah every episode is the exact same
pretty much literally it's like
it's it's yeah it's it's always
sarcoidosis and then you know yeah yeah
so but but thinking about how formulaic
that is watch watch John Oliver's Show
and it is a beat for beat identical
every single episode truth be damned
there was a um there was a 4chan Thread
about John Oliver that was like went
viral on Twitter and other places where
they were talking about how uh John
Oliver and their use of canned laughter
and canned Applause and their pause
lines and the fact that they won't give
you a beat to think right now it's
programmatic it's completely predictive
program and then when covet hit they had
no audience and their shows were tanking
because they had to use laugh tracks and
it wasn't the same thing as a studio
audience being told to applaud because
every studio audience that goes there
they're told hey guys you got to give
this a lot of energy you gotta clap you
gotta go crazy did you see the the
Trevor Noah yeah during the pandemic
yeah I loved it have you ever seen have
you ever seen Theory without the laugh
track no they they take an episode of
Big Bang Theory and they remove all the
laugh track and then you realize there's
not a single joke in the entire show
it'll be like Sheldon will come in and
he'll go what are you doing making
popcorn
that yes I'm making popcorn yeah Big
Bang Theory sucks
that's what John Oliver is too take away
the laughing and he's like little
Timothy over here these you know and
that's it and and I I you know I
understand them The Meta implications of
this uh of this comment but John Oliver
and Trevor Noah any of these guys
couldn't hang with even like a basic
YouTuber like none of them could walk
through that door and be able to hang on
the show well everything everything was
scripted everything's carefully curated
and it's kind of sad what happened to
Comedy because just a few years ago we
had Jon Stewart was funny like I'll give
him that he has a ton of talent I just
don't respect it all the way but but
still you compare today's comedians to
Bill Hicks Richard Pryor George Carlin
Eddie Murphy oh yeah those people leaned
into controversy and used it as a way to
make fun of orthodoxies to question the
narratives and to bring attention to
themselves and to their art now and I
think I think some people people are
criticizing Tim's Point here about Dave
kind of bowing down but but I wish kind
of Dave would have kind of embraced him
more he made it very serious and I wish
he he you know he he did it because he
genuinely wanted to do it but I wish he
would have ended by just slam dunking as
much as he could and just going over the
top and just bringing it to a point
where again laughter was the focus and
not seriousness because when he does
walk away from it and says I'm done guys
and he kind of nods his head and he's
unhappy he does kind of open up this
window that allows this larger protest
to come in to fill that vacuum that he
sucked out of that room that he sucked
out of that stadium with that
seriousness so I you know when it came
when I saw Dave Chappelle that's exactly
what the feeling was like and he was
still working on that gig he ends with
his friend killing herself and that's
like the end of the show and that's and
that's you know and you leave and you're
like what was that well that goes into
the whole kind of negative energetic
Circle but we have to ask ourselves what
would George Carlin do what would
Richard Pryor do in these situations and
they would double down triple down and
make fun of this entire situation
because there's a lot of Comedy here
that video of of the guy saying we like
Dave getting harassed I mean there's so
much room to work with and we're living
in a situation where we can't even laugh
at these things or we're going to be
threatened to be censored or canceled no
I don't want to live like that I want to
live with people standing up and and and
and and fighting for one of the most
important rights there is and that's the
right to have satire
so that's my point of view and I always
said it's going to be a dark day when
the sensors the YouTubes figure out how
to go after satire and I think they're
encroaching on Dave and it's not going
to end with Dave but Dave you know again
I I like that special but I wish there
was more I wish there was more of a more
of a more of a ending on I'm still gonna
laugh at you guys cowards and cultists
take took over our major institutions
our media our and big Tech I remember uh
Twitter first between the Free Speech
party wow huh I don't know what happened
to Jack Dorsey and his crew but they
immediately just dropped to their knees
and said you know I will do whatever you
say
and now you end up with Netflix I think
they were always cowards if you look at
Hollywood but it now it's just
transparent with the internet I
definitely was so disgusting for so long
I still is I definitely think Jack
Dorsey is a coward I definitely
definitely think that because you know
talking to him privately when I did back
in you know several years ago now he was
talking about the need for people to you
know have their social media be
immutable and you can't take people down
and things like that he was talking
about how we need a path to Redemption
just Banning someone permanently for
these infractions is is not you know
it's not just and he does nothing yeah
it was kind of amazing when you'd hear
him say that stuff and I remember
listening to your um your I wouldn't
call it a Throwdown but discussion right
and it almost sounds like Jack Dorsey
the person does still kind of have that
feeling right but there's a coward he
doesn't do anything about it and you
hear oh yeah path to Redemption that
sounds good or like a rehabilitation
program or any of these various things
and yet none of them ever come to
fruition and you just kind of get the
sense that this guy is not the one who's
actually in control of his